VOICEOVER: Meet ART. The Amphibious Robot Turtle.
As its name suggests art is a robot
that can swim in water and walk on land.
And it's all down to a clever party trick.
It has legs that can turn into flippers.
According to the team of researchers
behind the 'bot', this shape-shifting
ability has the potential to make art more
efficient than existing amphibious machines.
ROBERT BAINES: So some robot
designers will say, okay
we know propellers work well in water
to move around, we know wheels work well
on land - so let's make a robot - put
propellers on it and put wheels on it.
In water a propeller might be
very efficient but on land,
it doesn't really allow the robot to move.
But it ends up being additional
weight on the robot, additional space.
VOICEOVER: This is where art
makes its efficiency gains.
Instead of having separate components
to move in water and on land, ART's
morphing limbs can adapt to suit both,
removing the need for redundant parts.
ROBERT BAINES: So these are the two
modes of the morphing limb. So on
my right here we have the flipper mode,
which is this flat hydrodynamic shape.
And then on my left here we have the leg
mode which is this shape - cylindrical and
load bearing and we have a little curvature
on the end of the limb that gives it some
surface area so that it can contact
the ground and not not just fall over.
VOICEOVER: Creating this limb
required some principles from
the rapidly growing field of soft robotics.
ROBERT BAINES: on the outside there's
a balloon that inflates and gives the
limb its shape and on the inside, bonded to
this balloon, is a material that changes its
stiffness. When it's heated up past a certain
temperature it becomes very soft and pliable.
And so using these materials we can transition
from The flipper to the leg or from the leg to
the flipper, that can walk on land or swim
in water - or transition between the two.
VOICEOVER: But creating adaptable
limbs was just the first step.
Next they needed to program ART with
patterns of movement known as gaits to
make use of these morphing materials. And
for inspiration as you might have guessed
they turned to turtles and their
terrestrial counterparts tortoises.
ROBERT BAINES: So the walking gait is
called a creeping gait. This isn't the
fastest gait but it's similar
to a tortoise - so if you look
at a tortoise they have sort of this amble
where they're lifting their legs up slowly,
one by one. And this is what this
creeping gait was inspired by.
So we also have a gate that's inspired more
by, for example sea turtles, and this is
the quintessential flapping motion you
would see a sea turtle doing - sort of
a quasi-figure eight pattern in which the
flipper is coming up and then coming down
and it's changing its angle with respect
to the the forward direction all the while.
VOICEOVER: These two gates seem to do the job
well on land and in water but ART ran into some
difficulty on the awkward terrain between the two
environments which is often sandy stony or muddy,
and ART often slipped or got stuck. So the
team opted for another less elegant solution.
ROBERT BAINES: So we looked at beaching
sea turtles and basically the locomotion
strategy they use, which is lying
on their stomachs and then pulling
themselves forward. And is not particularly
graceful but shifting the gait really gave
us a little more versatility
in where the robot could go.
VOICEOVER: The researchers calculated metrics for
ART's efficiency by measuring how much power it
used and how fast it was able to move for its
weight in different settings. And armed with
its morphing limbs and shifting gaits, ART was
able to match or outperform many exclusively
terrestrial or exclusively aquatic robots - while
still being able to move in both environments.
Of course art is still a work in progress. Right
now, for example, it's tethered meaning its power
supply and programming centre aren't housed
within the body itself. But in the future
the team hopes that morphing amphibious
'bots' loaded with sensors or cameras like
you can see here could be used for things like
ecological monitoring or even disaster response.
And their shape-shifting approach to
robot design doesn't have to stop there.
ROBERT BAINES: So I don't think it's necessarily
confined to just a robot with morphing limbs.
This idea can be extended where we have robot
bodies that morph more drastically to specialise
for different types of locomotion, different
tasks. I think if people see the potential
efficiency gains, shape morphing lends itself to
adaptability in a variety of robotic applications